excellente année pour ce premier journal
de 2015 nous reviendrons sur la
mobilisation des médecins libéraux la
grève entamée pendant les fêtes se
poursuivra lundi le secteur de la santé
inquiet de la réforme à venir les
conséquences du mouvement auprès du
service médical de garde à Montini le
Bretonneux réquisitionné à quelques
jours de la rentrée nous ver que
certains élèves à voisin le Bretonneux
viennent de passer des vacances
studieuses l'association Archimède
propose des remises à niveau de la
primaire au lycée et puis retour sur cet
engouement des Français pour la revente
des cadeaux de Noël c'est sans complexe
que depuis une semaine certains
n'hésitent pas à venir par exemple ici à
morpa récupérer un peu d'argent contre
les présents qu'ils viennent de
déballer le réveillon du Nouvel An
plutôt calme dans les Yvelines des
moyens importants déployés par la
préfecture dans les villes jugées les
plus à risque n'ont pas évité attrape
notamment des destructions de véhicules
31 voiture ont brûlé sur les routes
aucun décès aucun accident grave là
aussi policiers gendarmes sont
intervenus tout au long de la nuit afin
de faire la chasse au conducteurs sous
l'emprise d'alcool ou de drogue des
opérations que le préfet souhaitait à la
fois préventive et
répressives réquisitionn le 23 décembre
dernier ces médecins généralistes
commençaient leur mouvement à la maison
de garde de Montini le Bretonneux les
praticiens ont été réquisitionné en tout
près de 170 personnes ont été reçues les
soirées sont traditionnellement pas des
des des moment où l'activité est
vraiment très très importante puisque
généralement on voit entre 0 et 5
personnes là il y a eu en fin de en
début de semaine le 29 et le 30 une
suractivité notable puisque je pense
qu'on a on a atteint 14 15 personnes sur
les les tranches de de nuit ce qui
arrive carrément jamais même dans
période épidémique après 2 semaines de
mobilisation les médecins généralistes
ont le sentiment de ne pas avoir été
entendus les syndicats appellent à une
grève administrative touchant
l'utilisation de la carte Vitale dès le
lundi 5 janvier pour le patient ça
applique pas grand-chose c'est vrai que
le la la la carte Vitale c'est juste le
moyen de
pouvoir signifier que l'acte a été
réalisé et induire pas de cette façonl
le remboursement de la caisse au
patients par contre pour la caisse ça
change puisque effectivement elle doit
traiter des feuilles et et ça se fait
plus de façon automatique avec avec la
caritale le mouvement de greffe continue
au moins jusqu'au 6 janvier la maison de
garde restera
ouverte le Centre d'hébergement de
mortemet propose 65 lit à l'année mais
quand les structures du S5 sont
débordées il peut toujours accueillir
des personnes pour la nuit
exceptionnellement là au niveau de la
préfecture et puis de la de la des dcs
ils nous ont demandé de éventuellement
dépanner le 115 si il y avait des
personnes qui étaient éventuellement
dehors donc là on dépanne 5q personnes
euh on a dépanné cinq personnes hier
soir ce soir et jusqu'au 31 c'est dans
le réfectoire que les cinq hommes
d'origine tibétaine ont passer la nuit
sans couchage disponible mais au moins
il y fait chaud le centre essaie de
récupérer des VI de camp pour un
meilleur accueil on les reçoit on leur
donne à manger on les accueille et puis
après une fois que la journée se termine
la journée c'est dire en fait après le
repas de 19h30 il y a le ménage qui se
met en place il y a la salle commune qui
vit où les gens font des jeux la
télévision a 23h on éteint effectivement
toutes les on éteint le sang quoi
extinction des feux et à partir de là
ben ils peuvent se reposer
tranquillement Zola lui a quitté la
structure il y a 2 mois il a aujourd'hui
son propre logement mais reste en
contact avec le centre la Harry
j'ai je la suite à personne en tout cas
donc c'est dur de sur pendant
l'hiver on sait que bon cette année je
sais pas si est passé tous les ans l' il
y a tou des morts Les morts de la rue
300 domiciles fixes ont été retrouvés
sans vie le weekend dernier en France si
le froid perdure le centre continuera à
ouvrir ses
portes ce matin pour Enzo et Camila
c'est cours de mathématiqu et avec les
fêtes pas facile d'être toujours bien
concentré quce qui important c'est un
peu bizarre je préfère d'être en
vacances jouer alors je pense que c'est
c'est mieux comme ça j'auraai moins
d'hésitation quand je quand je serais
revenu de vacances en en classe des
mathématiques du français de l'anglais
de la physique et des cours en petit
groupes pas plus de quatre ou C par
classe de quoi bien travailler les
points faibles quand on est à Noël pas
je ne sais pas si S rendre bien compte
mais je le redis on a fait bien 40 % des
heures de l'année quand on arrive à Noël
c'est vraiment le bon moment pour avec
les résultats du trimestre se dire où
est-ce qu'on doit intervenir du cma1 à
la terminale 50 élèves sont venus
étudier avec l'association ces lycéens
veulent remonter leur notes mais ont
surtout un plus grand objectif ça permet
de de se remettre à niveau et
recommencer l'année de bon pied pour
mieux réussir bah près pour le bac
évidemment donc du coup coup surtout se
remettre dedans par que des fois les
vacances on oublie un petit peu on perd
un petit peu le fil c'est surtout pour
l'objectif B pour avoir une une assez
bonne mention pour être reçu dans dans
les établissements supérieurs il est
bientôt 11h quelques minutes encore à
travailler avant une pause bien
méritée vendre une ancienne console une
vieille console avec des jeux parce que
mes enfants on une nouvelle console à
Noël donc voilà ça me permet de racheter
quelques jeux ici une vieille console
des années 90 reprise ici à 13 € 2 € de
plus avec les jeux vidéos c'est juste
pour pas la jeter parce que ça fait mal
au cœur quand même de jeter aujourd'hui
on on pense avoir une dizaine de
personnes ou une vingtaine de personnes
qui vont venir nous revendre un ou des
cadeaux de Noël qu'elles ont reçu dont
elles ne sont pas satisfaites qu'elles
ont eu en double qui ne plaisent pas aux
enfants qui ne plaisent pas aux adultes
en ce mois de décembre l'affluence est
augmentée
la fin de l'année c'est 50 % des ventes
en plus par rapport à un mois normal ce
sont aussi des effectifs à la hausse
deux personnes complémentaires sont
arrivés pendant cette période pour
compléter l'équipe des 10 salariés
permanents ce sont des très grosses
périodes et si on fait 100 au mois
d'octobre on fait 150 160 au au mois de
décembre anaïs est venu en famille
apporter une ancienne console de jeux le
prix de reprise 35 € avec les jeux
vidéos j'avais envie de vendre mes
vieilles consoles et vu que je savais
qu'iled donna des sous bah voilà les
vendeurs repartent avec de l'argent
liquide si la transaction est inférieure
à 700 €. en cas de vente de bijoux ce
sera uniquement par chèque acheter ces
produits d'occasion au bon prix en
fonction de l'offre et la demande c'est
aussi tout le travail de Patrice et de
son
équipe on va comparer le prix notre prix
de vente avec les prix qu'on peut
trouver sur internet sur certains site
bien connu de tout le monde et on va
partir de cette base pour effectuer
notre prix de V et par conséquent
effectuer notre prix d'achat et ensuite
notre prix d'achat dépend aussi dans de
nombreux cas de l'offre et la demande si
on a un jeu vidéo que tout le monde
cherche on va pouvoir le revendre et
l'acheter très bien si on a 20 jeux
vidéos que personne ne souhaite on va
pas l'acheter très très cher le magasin
de morpa est ouvert depuis bientôt 5 ans
600000 visiteurs fréquentent le lieu à
l'année au total sur une année 50000
tickets de caisse sont enregistrés avec
un panier moyen d'achat autour de 43 €
légèrement en baisse
en 2014 le chiffre d'affaires du réseau
a atteint 120 millions d'euros soit une
progression de 224 % depuis 5 ans ce
réseau emploie au total 900 salariés
pour cette période de fête de fin
d'année le magasin de morpa a reçu
plusieurs milliers de
personnes petite citadine voiture de
rally ou Formule 1 Bernard bitu aime
toutes les voitures sans conditions
aujourd'hui retraité cette ancien
ingénieur en mécanique retrace sa vie
entre souvenir de conducteur et pilote
de rally amateur à travers son livre
autobiographie su aperçu que les gens ne
savaient plus ce que c'était que une NSU
par exemple une sim Camille à peine donc
j'ai trouvé salutaire de faire ce livre
j'ai voulu marquer une certaine époque
l'époque des amateur qui permettait de
courir avec sa voiture on remplaçit les
roues on remplaçait le pot d'échappement
et hop on partait il lui aura fallu 4
ans de travail pour se remémorer ses
souvenirs accumulés en près de 67 ans du
circuit des 24 heures du MO à celui de
magncourt en passant par nogarou c'est
toute une époque qu'il retrace ce
panneau là on voit la
démarche d'un rally régional que
j'explique dans mon livre aussi parce
que c'est c'est des épreuves qui
n'existent plus maintenant par il
fallait faire une recherche alors que
avec le GPS tout est tout est permis
réveiller et révéler le fabuleux passé
de l'automobile ancienne à travers des
anecdotes toujours avec humour c'est là
l'objectif de Bernard c'est je me
prenais comme Michel Vaillant parce que
dans le dans un épisode
de qui s'appelle la Clé de 12 il y a le
problème de frein
et c'est arrivé d'après d'après le
circuit c'est mont li et moi j'ai eu les
mêmes problèmes de frein Michel ant est
toujours toujours gagnant donc euh pas
moi le 3 janvier à 15h Bernard bitu sera
à Montini le Bretonneux à la Ferme du
Manet pour présenter son livre mais il
espère surtout rencontrer d'autres
[Musique]
passionnés